He’s a man known to history literally as
‘the Terrible’.
Ivan IV was the first tsar of Russia, the
man who built the iconic St Basil’s Cathedral,
and the ruler who defended Moscow from Tartar
invasion.
In Russian history, he’s a towering figure,
behind perhaps only Peter the Great and Lenin
in how he shaped the nation.
Yet how much do any of us really know about
him, beyond his mistranslated nickname?
Could he really be so bad as the crazed, wild-eyed
caricature of popular history?
Well, no.
As it turns out, Ivan the Terrible was, if
anything, even more terrifying.
Elevated to ruler of Russia when he was just
a boy, Ivan showed sociopathic tendencies
from the get-go.
As a child, he was renowned for torturing
small animals.
As an adult, he had his opponents torn apart
by wild dogs.
A bloodthirsty king who killed his own son
and created a feared secret police, this is
the story of Russia’s sixteenth century
Stalin.
“An evil act will spawn an evil son”
On August 25, 1530, Vasili III gazed out the
window of his palace as a terrific storm battered
Moscow.
It was twenty years since the Grand Prince
had come to the throne, twenty long years
in which he’d tried fruitlessly for an heir.
Now, nearing the end of his life, his desperation
had got the better of him.
He’d divorced his first wife and remarried,
scandalizing Moscow.
One religious man had even prophesized that
this evil act would produce an evil heir,
one who would terrorize the country.
We can only wonder if Vasili III was reminded
of that prophecy as he looked out the window
at the storm wracking Moscow the night his
son was born.
The Russia Ivan the Terrible was born into
was very different from the one we know today.
For one thing, it wasn’t really called Russia,
but Muscovy, or The Grand Duchy of Moscow
if you want to be old fashioned.
For another, it was tiny.
Comparative to modern Russia, it was nothing;
a landlocked strip hemmed in on all sides
by rival states.
But it was something else, too.
The Muscovy of 1530 was weak.
The superpowers of the day were Poland-Lithuania
- which hadn’t technically yet become a
fully joint state, but was so close that we’re
just gonna say Poland-Lithuania to keep things
easy - and the Khanate of Crimea.
Alongside them were a hodgepodge of weaker
Islamic Khanates leftover from Ghengis Khan’s
Golden Horde, Khanates like Kazan, and Siberia.
Don’t worry about remembering all those
names, we’ll remind you of them when the
time comes.
Just know that, at the moment of Ivan’s
birth, Muscovy was a tiny outpost of Orthodox
Christianity surrounded by a sea of Islam
and Catholicism.
Not that this concerned young Ivan much.
He was a baby, too busy playing to care about
affairs of state.
That was what dad was there for.
Yeah, about that.
In 1533, Vasili III contracted an infection
which swiftly turned him from ‘strong king’
into ‘dying king’.
Sensing the end was near, the Grand Prince
summoned the boyars, a class of warrior nobles
who held much of Muscovy’s power.
Vasili made them swear loyalty to his son
Ivan, before setting up a regency with his
second wife Elena ruling in Ivan’s name.
That done, he promptly died.
Shortly after, on December 4, 1533, little
Ivan was proclaimed Grand Prince of Muscovy.
While this sounds like every spoiled brat’s
dream, the reality was less glamorous.
From that point on, his mother Elena insisted
he be surrounded at all times by armed guards
in case the boyars tried to kill him and assume
the throne.
But Elena needn’t have worried that the
boyars might kill little Ivan.
Why murder a child when it’s so much easier
to simply replace his regent?
On April 4, 1538, Elena died, almost certainly
assassinated by the boyars.
Her death set off an explosive power struggle
in the Muscovite court.
For Ivan, this meant spending his late childhood
trapped in a whirlwind of cruelty.
The boyars knew no limits.
Like warlords, they would do anything to keep
themselves in power.
In one instance, Ivan witnessed a mentor being
skinned alive for crossing a powerful family.
It was also a time of neglect.
Ivan would later recall that - despite living
in a palace - he wore only rags, and often
had to beg for food.
The only time the boyars cared about the young
Grand Prince was when some foreign dignitary
visited.
Then Ivan would be dressed up and paraded
about before being dumped back in his gilded
prison.
With all this cruelty around him, it’s perhaps
no surprise that Ivan began taking out his
anger on animals.
By age 12, he was torturing cats, much as
he’d witnessed the boyars torturing their
rivals.
But if the boyars thought they could cow this
weak and useless boy, they were about to learn
a terrible lesson.
Ivan may have barely been a teenager.
But already he was plotting his revenge.
Building The Third Rome
On December 29, 1543, a group of guards marched
into the quarters of one of the cruelest boyars
in Muscovy.
Saying they were following the Grand Prince’s
orders, the guards arrested the man, dragged
him away...and fed him alive to a pack of
wild dogs.
It was the Middle Ages equivalent of walking
into the prison yard and punching the biggest,
meanest skinhead smack in the mouth.
Aged only 13, Ivan had just ordered his first
gruesome murder.
From that point on, the boyars would show
him respect.
Not that Ivan did the same for others around
him.
By 14, the newly-confidant Grand Prince was
wandering the streets of Moscow with his teenage
friends, beating and robbing any citizen unlucky
enough to cross his path.
Yet it would be unfair to say that Ivan was
merely a thug.
At the same time he was getting a taste for
brutality, the boy was getting a taste for
something else, too.
Ivan was discovering religion.
Around the same time as his first murder,
Ivan had fallen under the sway of a Metropolitan
known as Macarius, who had impressed upon
Ivan the need for Muscovy to become a bastion
of Orthodox Christianity.
And Macarius knew just how to do that.
In 1547, Ivan’s regency finally came to
an end.
On January 16 , he was crowned Tsar Ivan IV
of all Russians in a lavish ceremony overseen
by Macarius.
This was a super big deal.
Ivan was the first person to be crowned tsar.
By using that title, and by using Byzantine
trappings in the coronation, Ivan and Macarius
were positioning Muscovy as the successor
state to the lost Byzantine Empire; the defender
of the Christian faith.
They even began calling Moscow the Third Rome.
Three weeks after this audacious ceremony,
Ivan held another one.
On February 3, 1547, Tsar Ivan IV married
a young girl called Anastasia.
You’ve probably never head of her, but you
have heard of her family.
Anastasia was from the Romanovs.
In the not-too distant future, her family
was going to transform Russia.
But only after Ivan had had his turn.
No sooner was the Terrible on the throne than
he was firing off edicts, reshaping Muscovy
with far-reaching reforms.
Surprisingly, not all these reforms were terrible.
To go through all of them would take forever,
but you can sum them up as being largely about
accountability.
In the mid-sixteenth century, the aristocrats
could generally get away with just beating
you to death in the street because they felt
like it.
Ivan’s new laws said “hey, actually, you
can’t just kill commoners for no reason.”
It may not sound like much but, coupled with
the introduction of localized government and
Muscovy’s first professional army, it was
a minor revolution.
Still, let’s not kid ourselves that Ivan
felt bound by his laws.
He’d designed them specifically to weaken
the power of the boyars.
When a bunch of commoners came to him to complain
about a corrupt official, Ivan had all 70
of them stripped naked in the snow before
setting their beards on fire.
Still, by the time his fifth anniversary on
the throne rolled around, Ivan was in a pretty
good place domestically.
He’d consolidated power, won the public’s
approval, and weakened the hated boyars.
Now he just needed his shiny new state to
find a way of living up to that whole Third
Rome thing.
And what better way to do that than to launch
a crusade?
The Fires of Victory
OK, time to check back in on all those neighbors
we mentioned earlier.
Remember?
The ones leftover from Genghis Khan’s Golden
Horde?
Well, the last few years had seen the Khanate
in Crimea growing bolder.
Tartar armies were starting to harry the fringes
of Muscovy.
But Crimea was far too strong for Ivan to
deal with now.
No, he and Macarius had their sights set on
somewhere a little closer to home: Kazan.
A minor Khanate sat on the Volga River, Kazan
was technically a threat to Muscovy, but was
actually a political basketcase.
That’s not to say they were helpless.
Over the years, many Muscovite armies had
tried to conquer Kazan, and just as many had
failed.
Now he was secure in his position, Ivan was
determined to show everyone how it was done.
On June 16, 1552, Ivan IV rode out at the
head of a vast army.
Since this was his first major war, it was
imperative that everything went well.
To that end, Ivan put aside hours per day
for praying, begging the Christian god to
help him crush the Muslim infidels.
It seemed God was listening.
On September 2, Ivan’s armies laid siege
to Kazan.
They cut off supplies, destroyed access to
drinking water, and built huge earthen works
to defend from cavalry attack.
By early October, it was over.
Kazan fell on October 13, just two days after
Ivan’s son Dimitri was born.
Although the Khanate tried to return, it was
effectively dead.
Ivan had done it.
Not just done it, but done it with astounding
ease.
Had he died now, it’s likely that Ivan would’ve
gone down in history as a great ‘What if?’,
a ruler history buffs singled out as someone
with the potential to be a legend.
This is worth thinking about, because, in
1553, Ivan really did nearly die.
That year, Ivan fell deathly ill.
Thinking it was the end, he did as his father,
Vasili III, had done, and summoned the boyars
to swear an oath to his son Dimitri.
This time, the boyars refused.
They prefered Ivan’s cousin.
If Ivan really was dying, he was just gonna
have to deal with this being the end of his
royal line.
However, Ivan didn’t die.
He recovered, but came back slightly changed.
Always a paranoid man, Ivan felt like his
illness had confirmed his darkest fears.
The boyars really were out to get him.
At that moment, Ivan vowed to get them first.
The Jaws of Defeat
Come winter, 1557, Ivan was looking for an
excuse to expand Russia’s boarders.
The year before, his armies had annexed the
other Khanate on the Volga, Astrakhan, giving
Muscovy clear access to the Caspian Sea.
But all the victory had done had convinced
Ivan that his new Russian state needed access
to an actual sea, one that connected to real
oceans.
One like the Baltic Sea.
In those days, Muscovy was bordered by something
known as Livonia, a state roughly analogous
to modern day Latvia and Estonia.
While Kazan had been a remnant of the Golden
Horde, Livonia was a remnant of the land the
Teutonic Knights had conquered.
But with the Knights now gone and Protestantism
on the rise, Livonia’s Catholic rulers were
starting to look weak.
Then, in December, 1557, King Sigismund of
Poland-Lithuania inserted himself into Livonia’s
affairs, forcing the nation to sign a treaty
with him.
For Ivan, this flagrant provocation was the
excuse he’d been looking for.
The moment the atrocious winter weather cleared
up, Ivan was leading a full-on invasion force
into Livonia, determined to carve a path to
the Baltic coast.
To say the war started well is to miss just
how easy a victory this was.
The new Muscovy armies steamrollered the Livonians.
By 1560, the Livonian Order was in ruins,
and its Grand Master had been dragged off
to Moscow and executed.
It should’ve been another easy win for Ivan.
Unfortunately, it was anything but.
In 1561, a new Grand Master was appointed
for Livonia.
With commendable slyness, he surrendered not
to Ivan, but to Sigismund, thereby giving
Poland-Lithuania a claim to the territory
Russia had occupied.
At the same time, the Grand Master ditched
his Catholicism and invited the Protestant
Swedes to invade and restore order in the
north.
And, just like that, Ivan found himself suddenly
stuck knee-deep in a war that would last the
next twenty years.
It couldn’t have come at a worse time.
In 1561, Ivan was still reeling from the double
whammy of his son Dimitri’s death, and the
suspected assassination of his wife, Anastasia.
Although Ivan still had two heirs - his sons
Ivan the younger and the mentally challenged
Fyodor - the sudden loss of two family members
still left him bitter.
When Metropolitan Macarius too passed away
in early 1563, Ivan seems to have lost it.
That same year, he beat one of his own soldiers
to death - the first murder the tsar committed
with his own hands.
But it was the events of April 30, 1564, that
would really make Ivan into ‘the Terrible’.
That day, Ivan’s best general, Andrey Kurbsky,
defected to the Lithuanians.
This seems to have floored Ivan.
Raging that the boyars were making a fool
of him, he announced he would abdicate the
throne.
You might expect the boyars to jump for joy
at this.
After all, this was the guy who’d had one
of their number thrown to wild dogs.
But this was war.
If the tsar left now, the power vacuum it
created would potentially cause Russia to
implode.
The boyars had no choice.
They begged Ivan to stay.
In early 1565, Ivan finally agreed, on one
condition: that he be allowed to create a
new mini-state within Russia itself, a place
where he would rule as God, without any checks
or balances.
Backed into a corner, the boyars agreed.
It was a decision that would set Muscovy on
the path
to Hell.
The Oprichnina
Shortly after, Ivan divided his
nation into two parts: the Zemschina and the
Oprichnina.
The Zemschina was
where things carried on as before, almost
unchanged.
The Oprichnina was where Ivan’s darkest
impulses came out to play.
The Oprichnina covered about a third of Muscovy’s
territory, but it wasn’t as simple as drawing
a line on a map.
Ivan was allowed to choose what he wanted
in his new kingdom, so naturally he selected
the richest towns, meaning the borders between
Oprichnina and Zemschina were often blurred.
In Moscow itself, the border could change
street by street, even house by house.
You might never know when you were suddenly
subject to Ivan’s whims.
And this was a problem, because it wasn’t
Ivan doing the Oprichnina’s dirty work.
It was the Oprichniki.
An army of around 6,000 men, the Oprichniki
were effectively Russia’s first secret police.
Dressed all in black, they rode black horses
and drove black carriages designed to instill
fear.
They were completely above the law, given
the right to torture, rob, rape or kill anyone
they felt like, and to burn down whatever
buildings they wished to.
Known as “children of darkness”, they
had one mission: to terrify the populace into
submission.
You better believe they succeeded.
To relate every awful thing the Oprichniki
did would result in this video being 10,000
hours long and giving all of us PTSD.
So let’s just stick to examples, like the
palace they used for their headquarters, where
it’s said twenty people were tortured to
death every single day.
Or like their sadistic commander, Malyuta
Skuratov, who liked to round up married women
from across Moscow and have them all raped
for his entertainment.
With Ivan’s blessing the Oprichniki targeted
boyar families, murdering or driving them
into exile, seizing the properties they left
behind.
By the end of the 1560s, they had turned so
many wealthy families into refugees that the
Oprichniki had managed to set themselves up
as a new aristocracy.
But where was Ivan in all this?
Leading from the front.
In early 1570, for example, Ivan became convinced
that the city of Novgorod was about to join
the Lithuanians.
There was no evidence for this.
In fact, Ivan had to make his rapist-in-chief
Malyuta Skuratov forge documents to “prove”
Novgorod was on the verge of rebelling.
Nevertheless, on January 2, Ivan rode out
at the head of a vast Oprichniki army.
For the next month, the Oprichniki were allowed
free run of Novgorod, killing, burning, maiming
like some demented, sixteenth century version
of The Purge.
Citizens were hanged by the hundreds.
Others were tied up and dumped into the ice-covered
river.
Those that managed to get back to the surface
had their heads caved in with axes.
By the time the Oprichniki left Novgorod on
February 12, there was no Novgorod left.
In one short month, the Oprichniki had killed
anywhere between 6,000 and 12,000 people.
Back in Moscow, Ivan followed this brutal,
pointless act by accusing boyars of conspiring
with Novgorod and having them executed.
By now, there was a feeling like nobody in
Muscovy was safe.
That this horror would never end.
However, help was about to come from an unlikely
source.
War is Over
The Oprichnina’s end came suddenly, in spring,
1571.
There were rumors that a Crimean Tartar force
was marching toward Moscow, but Ivan barely
bothered to prepare.
After all, his Oprichniki spies had told him
the force was a few thousand strong at best.
In fact, the advancing army contained over
120,000 soldiers.
By the time Ivan got the news, any chance
to fortify the city was gone.
So Ivan simply grabbed as much treasure as
he could and fled, leaving Moscow to its fate.
And what an awful fate it was.
The Tartars ransacked the city.
Muscovites were dragged away into slavery.
Children were slaughtered in their homes.
Every single building but the Kremlin was
burned to the ground.
By the time the Tartar force retreated, on
May 26, over 160,000 Muscovites were dead
or in chains.
So many bodies had been dumped in the river
that it had actually changed course.
The next year, Ivan abolished the Oprichnina.
Perhaps to cover his own failings, he also
unleashed a new terror against the Oprichniki
for failing to protect Moscow, paying back
blood with blood.
But it was little use.
Russia was by now a war-shattered ruin, with
an exhausted populace and an economy on the
brink of collapse.
Perhaps the only silver lining was that the
Crimean Tartar army finally overextended itself
shortly after and was crushed by regular Russian
forces.
Still, this offered only limited respite.
If Ivan were to save his nation, there was
only one thing he could do.
Ivan would have to end the Livonian War.
But he didn’t.
Although it was by now clear that his boneheaded
invasion of the Baltics had caused these endless
crises, Ivan still couldn’t give up his
old ways.
In the early 1570s, he even tried instituting
a new reign of terror, having his opponents
at home roasted alive.
But his real enemy was the senseless paranoia
in his own mind.
While Ivan was busy killing boyars, Poland-Lithuania’s
new king was invading Russia, and the Swedes
were reconquering Russia’s gains in Livonia.
Yet Ivan refused to listen to reason.
No matter what happened, he failed to see
that he himself was at fault.
However, while Ivan the Terrible was having
a truly terrible time, his son Ivan was doing
rather better.
A capable general, Ivan the younger had fought
the Polish-Lithuanian army in battle and acquitted
himself well.
So well, in fact, that the boyars wrote to
Tsar Ivan saying “hey, doofus.
Why not have this guy be leader, huh?”
They meant leader of the army.
But Ivan the Terrible thought they meant to
make his son tsar.
It was a suggestion he didn’t take kindly.
In November, 1581, shortly after receiving
the boyars’ petition, Ivan stumbled across
his son’s pregnant wife.
In a rage, he beat her so savagely that she
miscarried.
When his son came to complain, the old monster
grabbed his staff and hit the boy around the
head with it.
He kept right on hitting him until his skull
had broken and the floor was slick with blood.
Ivan the younger died of his injuries on November
19, 1581.
It’s said that Tsar Ivan reacted to his
passing by wailing “my God, what have I
done?”
But it was even worse than the puffed-up sadist
realized.
With Ivan the younger as dead as Dimitri and
Anastasia, the last heir to the throne was
Ivan’s simple-minded son Fyodor.
In just a few short years, Fyodor’s ascension
to the throne was going to both plunge Russia
into chaos, and end Ivan the Terrible’s
family line for good.
The Price of Peace
If nothing else, the death of Ivan the younger
seems to have finally focused Ivan’s crazed
mind.
In 1581, the Tsar of all Russians formally
asked the Pope to negotiate an end to his
war with Poland-Lithuania.
The eventual peace process saw Russia surrender
all its gains in Livonia.
A separate peace with Sweden saw Russia abandon
its claims to coastal towns on the gulf of
Finland.
After twenty four years of war… after the
deaths of hundreds of thousands of people…
Russia was right back where it had been in
1558.
All that horror.
All that suffering.
The Oprichnina, all of it.
All had been for nothing.
The only silver lining had been the destruction
of the Khanates in the early days of Ivan’s
reign, and the implosion of the Crimean army
after it sacked Moscow.
And the second of those had been in spite
of Ivan, rather than because of him.
Interestingly enough, Ivan scored one other
great victory in the last days of his reign
that had absolutely nothing to do with him.
In 1583, the Stroganoff family - yep, just
like the dish - rode a private army into Siberia
almost on a whim and defeated the Khanate
there.
This simple victory would open up Russian
expansion into Siberia for centuries to come,
providing a wealth of riches that would help
bring the nation back to its former glory.
So, um, well done Mr. Stroganoff.
By 1584, Ivan was so ill that even leaving
bed was too much for him.
His only solace was playing chess, something
he was doing on March 18 when a stroke allegedly
carried him off.
We say “allegedly” because it’s long
been rumored that the tyrant tsar was simply
strangled by fed-up boyars.
In the aftermath of Ivan’s death, Fyodor
took the throne, but was so useless that his
rule led to something called the Time of Troubles,
a fifteen year period of civil wars and uprisings
that made the Oprichnina look like Disneyland
constructed from unicorns.
In fact, the chaos Ivan the Terrible left
in his wake only cleared when Anastasia’s
old family, the Romanovs, finally seized power
in 1613.
At the end of all that, then, what can we
say about the man known to history as “the
Terrible”?
Well, he certainly lived up to his nickname!
Seriously, next time someone bangs on about
how “Terrible” is a mistranslation of
Grozny, just remember that, mistranslation
or not, “Terrible” is certainly appropriate.
But there are darker lessons we can take from
Ivan’s story.
The idea of an unaccountable leader who ruled
through fear, and of a secret police run by
sadists with no checks on their power would
return 500 years later, under perhaps the
only Russian leader more terrible than Ivan.
It’s said that Josef Stalin admired Ivan
the Terrible.
Maybe he felt a kindred spirit, calling to
him down through the years, encouraging him
to go even further, to commit even worse crimes
than had happened during the Oprichnina.
It’s often said that history repeats itself.
Well, even the briefest look at Russian history
will show you that Ivan’s tale repeated
itself again and again, like a record needle
stuck in a groove.
Ivan may have been the first crazed autocrat
to terrorize Russia.
But, he wouldn’t be the last.